It’s just our way of doing
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW HIM
FOR HIS PILLOWS BUT MICHAEL LIND
ELL WANTS YOU TO
KNOW AT LEAST IN THE NEAR FUTURE
, FOR HIS FACE MASKS
BECAUSE HE IS TRYING TO MAKE
SURE HE CAN MAKE AS MANY AS
POSSIBLE TO HELP SOMETHING
THAT IS IN SERIOUS SHORT SUPPLY,
AND THE CEO WITH US RIGHT NOW
MIKE GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON,
NEIL.
NEIL: SO TELL ME WHAT GOT YOU
DOING THIS AND WHY YOU’RE DOING
THIS AND HOW IT’S COMING ALONG
DOING THIS?
>> WELL IT WAS ABOUT THREE
WEEKS AGO AND I HEARD THE
PRESIDENT WANTED TO GET
EVERYBODY INVOLVED INVOLVED
IN EVERYTHING THEY COULD FOR
HELPING OUT THE MEDICAL
HOSPITALS AND EVERYTHING, AND I
STARTED DOING MY DUE DILIGENCE
IN FIGURING OUT WHAT WE COULD
MAKE AND HOW FAST I COULD RAMP
UP AND WHAT’S IN THE BEGINNING
OF THIS WEEK I FINALLY GOT DOWN
THE PROTOTYPE I WANTED AND WE
CONVERTED IN THREE DAYS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND SQUARE SQUARE
FOOT FACTORY, I’VE GOT ABOUT 300
OR  400 OF MY WORKERS CONVERTED
OVER AND WE’RE MAKING UP TO
10,000 MASKS A DAY AND I WANT TO
GET UP TO 50,000 BY NEXT WEEK.
NEIL: HOLY COW NOW WHO IS
GETTING THESE MASKS, YOU SHIP
THEM OUT TO NEW YORK?
>> YEAH, I’M GOING RIGHT TO THE
HOSPITALS AND THE FIRST
RESPONDERS, THINGS LIKE THAT.
MOSTLY RIGHT TO THE HOSPITAL.
THEY’VE HAD SINCE ITS KIND OF
BEEN ANNOUNCED I’VE BEEN TAKING
IN THE REQUESTS AND WE’RE TRYING
TO FILL THEM AS FAST AS WE CAN.
LAST NIGHT, I PERSONALLY WORKED
OVER THERE UNTIL ABOUT MIDNIGHT.
WE WORK AROUND THE CLOCK AND
IT’S JUST WE’RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND WE WANT TO GET
THROUGH IT AND I’M EVEN
LOOKING INTO FUTURE BEING ONE OF
THE MANUFACTURES THAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO STAY IN
THE U.S. , SO WE NEVER GO
THROUGH THIS PROBLEM AGAIN WITH
RELYING ON 95% OF OUR MEDICAL
SUPPLIES FROM CHINA.
NEIL: SO HOW MUCH OF THE
PRODUCTION OVERALL BETWEEN
THE PILLOWS AND BED SHEETS AND
SOME OF THE OTHERS IS COMPROMIS
ED BECAUSE YOU’RE DOING
THIS VERY GOOD, VERY PROMISING
DEED HERE.
>> WELL I’M ALWAYS VERY WELL
PREPARED IN MY PILLOW.
WE’RE VERY GOOD AT SCALING AND
SO I HAD TWO IDENTICAL FACTORIES
AND THE ONE I COMPLETELY
SWITCHED OVER AND I’M ABOUT 90%
OF MY SEWING DEPARTMENT FOR SURE
AND EVEN HIRING OTHERS AS FAST
AS I CAN, AND SO I WOULD SAY
ABOUT 90% OF WHAT I BE USING TO
PRODUCE PILLOWS BUT LIKE I SAY,
I HAVE A BIG STOCK, I’M ALWAYS
PREPARED FOR EMERGENCIES OR
THINGS THAT BIG SPIKES IN SALES
OR  WHAT HAVE YOU, AND SO THIS
HAS BEEN A BLESSING TO MY
WORKERS TOO TO BE ABLE TO HELP
OUT AND KEEP EVERYBODY GOING.
WE’VE HAD TO REDO THE FACTORIES
SO IT’S SAFE THERE.
EVERYBODY IS SIX FEET APART AND
DIFFERENT THINGS WE’VE PUT IN
PLACE, SO THEY FEEL SAFE COMING
TO WORK TOO.
NEIL: YOU’RE A GOOD MAN, MIKE,
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH, MIKE L
INDELL DOING HIS BIT TO
HELP THE COUNTRY EVEN IF IT
MEANS SOME OF HIS BUSINESS GETS